peter irons of the university of
california at san diego
and now we go to the oral argument in
the case miranda versus arizona argued
at the supreme court in 1966
i will wait just
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
mr flynn you may proceed now
chief justice
may please the court
this case concerns itself with the
conviction of a defendant
of two crimes of rape and kidnapping
sentences on each count
of 20 to 30 years to run concurrently
i should point out to the court in an
effort to avoid possible confusion
that the defendant was convicted in a
companion case of the crime of robbery
in a completely separate and independent
act
however the supreme court of the state
of arizona treated that
conviction as a companion case in a
companion decision
and portions of that record have been
appended to the record in this case as
it bears on the issue before the court
now the issue before the court is the
admission in evidence
of the defendant's
confession under the backs and
circumstances
of this case
over the specific objection of his trial
counsel
that it had been given in the absence of
counsel
the trial court in
june of 1963 prior to this court's
decision in escobedo
allowed the confession into evidence
the supreme court of the state of
arizona in april of 1965
after this court's decision in escobedo
affirmed
the conviction
and the admission of the confession in
evidence
this court has granted us review
the facts in the case indicate that the
defendant was a 23 year old
spanish-american extraction
that on the morning of march 13
1963 he was arrested at his home
taken down to the police station by two
officers named young and cooley
that at the police station he was
immediately placed in a lineup
he was
there identified by the prosecutrix in
this case
and later identified by the prosecutrix
in the robbery case
and immediately after the interrogations
he was taken into the police
confessional
at approximately 11 30 a.m
and by 1 30 they had obtained from him
an oral confession well what's the
police professional
the interrogation room uh described in
the transcript is interrogation room
number two your honor please
he had denied his guilt according to the
officers at the commencement of the
interrogation
by 130 had confessed it
i believe that the record indicates that
in no time during the interrogation
and prior to his
confession his oral confession
was he advised either of his rights to
remain silent
of his right to counsel or of his right
to consult with counsel
nor indeed was such the practice in
arizona at that time
admitted by the officers in their
testimony
the defendant was then asked to sign a
confession
to which he agreed
the form handed to him to write on
contained a type statement as follows
which precedes his handwritten
confession i ernest a miranda do hereby
swear
that i make this statement voluntarily
and of my own free will
with no threats coercion or promises of
immunity
and with full knowledge of my legal
rights
understanding any statement i make
may be used against me
this statement was read to him by the
officers
and he confessed in his own handwriting
writing
throughout the interrogation the
defendant did not request counsel at any
time
in due course the trial court appointed
counsel to defend him in both cases
[Music]
and defense counsel requested a
psychiatric examination
which has been made a port the and the
medical report has been made a portion
of the transcript of the record in this
case as it enlightens us to apportion
or some of the factual information
surrounding the defendant
mr paul
sorry to erupt you but
you said that he was marked that miranda
was not uh
told that he might remain silent
did you say that that's correct is there
a dispute as to that
yes there is your honor and i believe it
arises as a result of the
appendix
and the robbery
uh conviction
in this respect i would answer your
honors question by referring to
page 51 of the petitioner's brief into
the appendix
excuse me page 52
at the top
which the question was asked by mr moore
the trial council
did you stay to the defendant at any
time before he made the statement you
are about to answer to
that anything he said would be held
against him
answer no sir
question you didn't warn him of that
answer
no sir
question did you warn him of his rights
to an attorney answer no sir mr moore we
object not monetarily given
mr turoff i don't believe that is
necessary the court overruled
on page 53
succeeding page
a portion of the same record
indicates further cross-exact further
examination
concerning this conversation
had you offered and starting
approximately one third down the page
had you offered the defendant any
immunity answer no sir
in your presence had officer cooley done
any of these acts answer no sir question
about what time did this conversation
take place officer answer approximately
1 30.
shortly after mrs mcdaniels made her
first statement is that correct answer
yes sir can you tell us now officer
regarding the charge of robbery what was
said to the defendant and what the
defendant answered in your presence
answer i asked mr miranda if you
recognized
and there the question terminates
i was preparing to page four of your
rape and would you say that officer
young
believes that miranda was told that he
need not answer that question
[Applause]
i was about to continue uh if there are
pleased to page 54 at which we find
a question you never warned him he was
entitled to an attorney or anything he
said would be held against him did you
answer we told him anything he said
would be used against him he wasn't
required by law to tell us anything
consequently this would answer your
honor's question except
bearing in mind that the record clearly
reveals that from the lineup and the
identification to the interrogation room
the officers established the time as 11
30
and that the confession was completed
and signed at 1 30
reading the testimony of the robbery
conviction
it is apparent to me
that the officers when they recite or
answered on page 54 of the transcript
that he'd been advised of his rights
were again relating to this formal typed
heading
which would be at 1 30 at the time he
signed the confession that hence there
really is no conflict in the record as
to when he was advised of his rights
[Applause]
[Music]
the further uh history relating to this
defendant found in the psychiatric
examination would indicate that he had
an eighth grade education
and is found by the supreme court that
he had a prior criminal record
and that he was mentally abnormal
he was found however to be competent to
stand trial
and legally sane at the time of the
commission of the alleged acts
but a critical aspect of the defendant's
case of confession
i think is eminently demonstrated when
during the trial the prosecutrix was
asked the question concerning
penetration in which she first responded
that she was that she thought it was by
finger
under questioning by the prosecuting
attorney
immediately thereafter she expressed
uncertainty as to the manner or method
of penetration and after some prompting
responded to the prosecuting attorney
that it had been in fact by the male
organ
on cross-examination she again expressed
the uncertainty
in relation to this penetration which of
course is the essential element of the
crime of first degree rape in the state
of arizona
when she
responded to his question that she
simply was unsure whether it had been by
finger or by penis
now of course the defendant's confession
neatly corrects this reasonable doubt
that otherwise would have been
engendered but in precise terminology he
wrote
asked her to lie down
and she did
could not get penis into vagina got
about one half
parenthesis half written inch in
the only thing missing or the only thing
that the officers failed to supply in
words to this defendant
at the time he wrote this confession was
in violation of section
13-611 arizona revised statutes
then of course they would have had the
classic confession of conviction because
they could have argued that the man even
knew the statutory provisions relating
to rape
the state as i read their response take
no issue with the statement of facts as
i've outlined them to this court except
to say that we overstate his mental
condition
and
minimize his educational background and
also the concern that is expressed
by mr justice fortis concerning at what
stage of the proceeding he may have been
advised of his right to remain silent
now the petitioner's position
on the issue is simply this
the arizona supreme court
we feel has imprisoned this court's
decision in escobedo on its facts
and by its decision
is refusing to apply the principles of
that case and for all practical purposes
has emasculated
certainly every court
designed to admit a confession
can find distinguishing factors
in escobedo from the back situation
before
i would like to very briefly quote from
the transcript of record
which contains the arizona decision at
page 87.
we'll will be noted that the court in
the escobedo case
set forth the circumstances under which
a statement would be held admissible
namely
one
the general inquiry into an unsolved
crime must have begun to focus on a
particular suspect
two
the suspect must have been taken into
police custody
three the police in its interrogation
must have elicited an incriminating
statement four
the suspect must have requested and been
denied an opportunity to consult with
his lawyer
five the police must not have
effectively warned the suspect of his
constitutional rights to remain silent
when all of these five factors occur
then the escobedo case is a controlling
precedent
now the arizona supreme court having
built or having indicated its clear
intention to impr imprison the dis the
escobedo decision
set about
to do it precisely that
first as to the focusing question
it indicated that this crime had
occurred at night
and consequently despite the positive
identification of the defendant by two
witnesses which the state urged were in
entirely fair lineups the supreme court
of arizona indicated that even then
perhaps under these facts attention had
not focused upon this defendant
i think this is sheer sophistry and
would clearly indicate the obvious
intent of the arizona supreme court to
confine escobedo and to distinguish it
whenever possible
next the court found that the defendant
was advised of his rights in the reading
of the type portion immediately
preceding its transcript they permitted
that document to lift itself by its own
bootstrap so to speak and to indicate
that here was a man who was
knowledgeable concerning his legal
rights despite the facts and
circumstances of his background and his
education
and they further found that he was
knowledgeable because he had a file
criminal record to win the decision they
indicated this would be knowledge of his
rights in court and certainly not his
rights at the time of the interrogation
i think the numerous briefs filed in
this case
indicating the substantial split in the
decisions
throughout the various
states
the circuits and the federal district
courts
indicate the interpretation that has
been placed upon escobar
on the one hand we have the california
decision in dorado we have the third
circuit's decision in russo
which would indicate that principle and
logic are being applied to the decision
and the words of mr justice goldberg
that when the process shifts from the
investigation
to one of accusation
and when the purpose is to elicit a
confession from the defendant
then the adversary process
comes into being
on the other hand the other cases that
would distinguish this
have found
and give rise to what i submit is not
really confusion by merely straining
against
the principles and logic
in that decision
what do you think is the
result
of the adversary process coming into
being when this focusing takes place
what follows from that
is they're then a right to a
but a lawyer
i think that the man at that time has
the right to exercise if he knows and uh
under the present state of the law in
arizona if he's rich enough and if he's
educated enough to assert his fifth
amendment right
and if he recognizes he has a fifth
amendment right
to request counsel
i simply say that
at that stage of the proceeding under
the facts and circumstances in miranda
of a man of limited education
uh of a man who certainly is mentally
abnormal
who is certainly an indigent that when
that adversary process uh came into
being that the police at the very least
had an obligation to extend to this man
not only the his clear fifth amendment
right but to afford to him the right of
counsel
well i suppose if you're really mean
what you say or what you gather from
this from what yes opinion says
the adversary process that starts at
that point then every single protection
of the
constitution then comes into
being uh does not have the right to you
have to bring a jury in there i suppose
no your honor i wouldn't bring a jury
and i simply would extend to the man
those constitutional rights which the
police would at that time take it away
from him
my question is what are those rights
when this focusing begins there are
these all the panoply of rights
guaranteed to a defendant in the in a in
a criminal trial
i think that the first right is the
fifth amendment right not to incriminate
oneself the right to know that you have
that right and the right to consult with
counsel at the very least in order that
you can exercise the right
well i
i don't fully understand your uh
answer but because if if the adversary
process then begins then then what you
have the equivalent of a trial do you
not and then i suppose you have a right
to a judge and a jury and
everything else that goes through the
trial right then and there
and if you have something less than that
then you then this is not an adversary
proceeding then you don't mean what
you're saying
i think what i say when i'm interpreting
adversary proceeding to me
that at that time
a person who is poorly educated who in
essence is mentally abnormal who is an
indigene
to if he is an adversary proceeding at
the very least he is entitled to at that
stage of the proceeding to be
represented by council and to be advised
by council of his rights under the fifth
amendment of the constitution or he has
no such
well again i uh i don't need to quibble
and i apologize but i
think it's first important to define
what those rights are what his rights
under the constitution are at that point
now you can't be advised of his rights
unless uh somebody knows what those
rights are
precisely my my point and the only
person that can adequately advise a
person like ernest miranda is a lawyer
and what's the lawyer advising that his
rights then were that he had the right
not to incriminate himself that he had a
right not to make any statement that he
had the right to be free further
questioning by the police department
that he had the right at ultimate time
to be represented adequately by
counseling court that if he was too
indigently poor to employ counsel that
the state would furnish him counseling
and what is it that confers the right
to a lawyer's advice at that point and
not and not at an earlier point
the absolute message the sixth amendment
no the attempt to erode or to take away
from him the fifth amendment right which
already existed and that was the right
not to incriminate himself and to be
convicted out of his own mind
didn't he have that right earlier
if he knew about before this became a
so-called adversary
yes your honor if you knew about
what he was aware of
it was knowledgeable then didn't he have
the right to a lawyer's advice earlier
if he could afford it yes he was
intelligent enough strong enough to
stand up against police interrogation
and requested yes
what i'm getting at is i don't
understand the magic in this
phrase of focusing then all of a sudden
it becomes an adversary proceeding and
then i suppose if you literally mean
that it becomes an adversary proceeding
then you're entitled to all the rights
that a defendant is given under our
constitution at a criminal trial
and if you mean less than that then then
you don't really mean it's now become
the equivalent of a trial
well i simply mean that when it becomes
an adversary proceeding at the very
least a person in earnest miranda's
position
needs the benefit of counseling and
unless he is afforded that right to
council he simply has
in essence no fifth or sixth amendment
right and there is no due process of law
being afforded to a man in earnest
miranda's position
is it possible that uh
prior to this so-called focusing or
let's say prior to
arrest knowing those don't mean the same
thing
that a citizen has an obligation to
cooperate with the state
give the state information
that he may have relevant to
a crime
that uh
upon
harass or upon this focusing
that
the state and the individual then assume
the position of adversaries
and there is at the very least a change
in that
relationship between the individual and
the state and therefore in their
mutual rights and responsibilities
i don't know that's what my brother
stewart's getting at in fact it's unfair
to discuss this through you
[Music]
is that without getting ourselves into
the area precisely when focusing begins
that i must in this instant limited to
the back situation and circumstances in
earnest miranda
because for every practical
purpose
after the two-hour interrogation
the mere formality of supplying counsel
to ernest miranda time of trial
and what i would submit would really be
nothing more than a mockery of the
assertion of his sixth amendment rights
to be represented in court to go through
the formality of the trial and eviction
takes place
while this simply is not
a
matter of the record
uh it's in the robbery trial and i think
it is
illustrates the position of what occurs
in the case of persons who have
confessed as ernest miranda
a question was asked in the robbery
trial which receded the rape trial by
one day
of mr moore the court are you ready to
go to trial mr moore i have been ready i
haven't anything to do but from my man
and sit down and listen
let me ask you one question
that the first amendment let's forget
that this
amendment that provides no person should
be compelled to be a witness and yet
disassociated entirely from the right
account
you said several times seemed to
indicate that
in determining whether or not a witness
witnessed the person should be compelled
to commit himself it might defend to
some extent on his literacy
or illiteracy his wealth or his lack of
wealth his standard nor his lack of
spending
why does that have anything to do with
it why does the amendment not compare
not to protect the rich as well as the
poor
illiterate as well as the hillary
i'd say that it certainly most assuredly
does protect what is that that in the
state of the law today as uh pronounced
by the arizona supreme court under those
guiding principles it certainly does
protect the rich the educated and the
strong those rich enough to hire a
council those who are educated enough to
know what their rights are and those who
are strong enough to withstand police
interrogation and assert those rights
and does not afford protection i'm
asking you only about the fifth
amendment provision
no person should be compelled to be a
witness yes conservative
does that protect every person
or just some person
i'm not talking about in practical
effects
i'm talking about what the amendment is
supposed to do protects all persons
incriminating or convicted
or illiterate to have anything to do
with it if they compel him to testify
whatever that whatever comes within the
scope of that
at the interrogation stage if he simply
is too ignorant to know that he has the
fifth amendment right then certainly
literacy has something to do with the
toronto
if the man at the time of the
interrogation has never heard of the
fifth amendment knows nothing about its
concept or its scope knows nothing of
his right then certainly
his literacy uh
you'd have more rights because of that i
don't understand
not to be compelled to be a witness
against themselves
what does that cover perhaps i have
simply not expressed myself does that
cover everybody covers everybody your
honor
clearly in practical uh application
in view of the interrogation and the
uh
facts and circumstances of miranda it
simply had no application because of the
facts and circumstances in that
particular case that's what i'm
attempting to express to the court
now the arizona supreme court
went on to
to
in essence we submit
turn its decision primarily on the
failure of the defendant in this case to
request counsel
which is the only really distinguishing
factor that they could find
very claim in this case that this
confession was compelled
was involuntary no your honor not at all
none at all
there's no question that
he was not compelled to give evidence of
his concern we have not raised no
question that he was
compelled to give this statement for a
sense that anyone forced him to do it by
coercion by threats
by promises
for propulsion of that time well that uh
was he was voluntary or was it
voluntary in the sense that uh the man
at a time without knowledge of his
rights
i would say that his fifth amendment
right was violated
because he was compelled to do it that's
what it was
yes to the extent that he was number one
to poor point exercises number two
mentally abnormal whatever the fact is
you say it was compelled to do it
i say it was taken from him
at a point in time when he absolutely
should have been in the section
amendment namely the term the provision
that he was
to violate him and his fifth amendment
right has to be compelled to do it
doesn't he
in the sense that your honor is
presenting to me the word compelled
you're correct
you know i was talking about the
constitution
he doesn't have to have a gun point to
the tree because of course he doesn't
so he was compelled to do it wasn't he
and yet according to
not by gunpoint uh
mr justice black has indicated he was
called upon to surrender a right but he
didn't fully realize and appreciate that
he had in all
i'm just trying to find out if you claim
that sentimental rights were violated
and said if they were it must be you can
tell that you say you can tell me
i would say that as a result of lack of
knowledge
or lack of a better term uh failure to
advise
the denial of a right to counsel the
stage of the proceeding we most
certainly need it needed it this could
in and of itself
and certainly in most policies
why would that not tend to show
some kind of coercion of compulsion
the whole process of a person having
been raised i would assume to tell the
truth to respect authority was he
allowed to get away from that will
know your honor he was in confinement
under arrest the state had moved against
him by taking him into question
that is correct
i suppose
foreign you would say that uh
if the police had uh
said to this young man now
you're a
nice young man and we don't want to hurt
you and
so forth we're your friends
and uh
if you'll just tell us
how you committed this crime
we'll let you go home and we won't
prosecute you
that uh that that would be a violation
of the fifth amendment and that
technically speaking would not be
compelling to do it it would be an
inducement wouldn't it that's great it
would i suppose you would argue that
that is still uh within the fifth
amendment wouldn't you it's an
abdication of the fifth amendment rights
simply because
that's what i mean total circumstances
existing at the time the arrest the
custody uh the lack of knowledge the
[Music]
as i recall in those cases i agree with
the chief judgment
that was put on the fifth under the
fifth amendment
and the words of the fifth amendment was
referred to in the early case by
chief justice white i believe it brought
uh the fact that inducement is a
compulsion
and was
brought in that category
therefore it violated
the amendment against being compelled to
give evidence against yourself
i'm sure mr justice black
question
what compelled me
but does not depend
i suppose i haven't seen it in any of
the cases
on the wealth understanding for the
status of the person so far as the right
is concerned yes i think perhaps that
was a bad choice of words and context
your honor please at the time i stated
i would like to state that uh in
conclusion
that the constitution of the state of
arizona for example has since statehood
provided to the
citizens of our state
language
precisely the same as the fourth
amendment to the federal constitution as
it pertains to searches and seizures
and yet from 1914
until this court's decision in map
versus ohio we simply did not enjoy
the
fourth amendment rights or the scope of
the fourth amendment rights that were
enjoyed by most of the citizens of the
other states of this union and those
persons who were under federal control
in response to the amicus from new york
and for the
amicus for the
national association of defense
attorneys that would ask this court
to go slowly and to give the
uh opportunity to the states to the
legislature to the courts
and to the bar association to undertake
to solve this problem
i simply say that whatever the solutions
may be it would be another 46 years
before the sixth amendment right
in the scope that it was intended i
submit by this court in escobedo will
reach the state of arizona
where one of the most modern states in
relation to the
adoption of the american law institute
rules we have a comparable rule to rule
five to my knowledge
there has never been a criminal
prosecution for failure to arraign a man
and there is no decision in arizona that
would even
come close to the
mcnabb or maori rules in arizona in fact
the same term that miranda was decided
the arizona supreme court indicated that
despite
the necessity and requirement of an
immediate arraignment before the nearest
and most accessible magistrate that
mallory versus mcnabb did not apply
[Music]
mr nelson
[Applause]
mr chief justice
made please the court
counsel
[Music]
somewhat
caught up in where to begin i think
perhaps the
first
and most important to one of the most
important things to say right now is
concerning mr
aflensworth last remarks i as a
prosecutor
even a
only short duration
take serious issues
strenuous the strenuous issue as i can
take before this court
in the statement that it will take
another 46 years in the state of arizona
for the right to counsel to become
full-blown
i just
simply think there is no reason for that
statement to be made if there's any
reason for it to be made
any possible justification for it to be
made then there's no point in uh
in going any further
one of the issue that might be a good
starting point
is concerning the description of the
arizona courts
supposedly
off-the-cuff referral to or
ignoring of the escobedo decision
or the attempt to avoid it clearly
there is no such thing in the arizona
supreme court opinion and a reading of
it shows that
they agree that they must follow this
court not begrudgingly they simply state
it that it's a fact
and then in exploring the case of
escobedo
the case of miranda
they try to find out
what happened in miranda what the case
of escobedo says
and apply those principles there's
there's no attempt
to avoid
and i don't think you can read it
implicitly or otherwise in the arizona
court's opinion
clearly they did not base it on a
request
they did not say
uh we have a b c d e and
d wasn't present therefore it's not
controlling that was not what they said
they said many courts and other
jurisdictions had gone off on that
particular area they mentioned that as a
factor but they discussed hundreds of
hundreds but many other factors in
miranda which differentiated it from
escobedo
to get to the facts
in miranda
i think
it's very clear from the record
that mr miranda
[Music]
as an individual defendant
does not
particularly require any special rules i
certainly agree with mr justice black
100
that the fifth amendment the sixth
amendment every other part of our
constitution applies to everyone poor
rich ignorant intellectual what have you
there's no possible basis for
differentiation i don't argue that i
don't think any prosecutor of note
argues
but miranda i think
characteristically by the petitioner is
portrayed in this life
in an attempt to make something that
isn't there
sure he only went through the eighth
grade
and
one of the psychiatrists said he had an
emotional illness
i might say
there is another
psychiatric report
it's not in the printed record and i
just discovered in my file
uh but it is in the record before this
court the record that was
on appeal and i would urge the court to
advert to that psychiatric report also
and as to the fact that mr miranda could
not have made the statement
that he made
i just don't think there's any basis for
alleging that the fact that he uses
the words uh the medical words to
describe the
male and female sex organ rather than
some four letter vernacular words that
he might have used this doesn't condemn
him
just because he knew those words and
maybe felt in this context in writing a
statement that
he could use them
there's no indication in the record that
the police put these words in his mouth
the fact that the this particular
one-half inch penetration
uh
is something that the police
conjured up in his mind is just simply
not
supportable by the record you read the
psychiatric report and
that is in the record and he said he was
upset when he found out that she had not
had sexual relations before well she
told him that the only way he found out
was because uh obviously from the record
as he said
he uh was only able to make penetration
uh
only a slight waste simply because the
fact that
that the warren's
climate has nuts and ruptured this is a
clear factual as to that he knew why he
made that statement and why it was
accurate not the application of the
police officers mr nelson on page 19 of
your briefing
you
assert that
the petitioner was advised for his
constitutional rights
specifically including his right to
remain silent
the fact that his statement had to be
voluntary
and that anything he did say could be
used against him yes sure i wouldn't say
the only basis for that the uh printed
legend in the confession that he signed
no i i don't believe i would have put in
as strong a statement concerning his
right to remain silent had not
we agreed
to stipulate to this other portion of
the other record
but i believe that
as long as that's in the record i can
make this statement because it's
supported in the finding of the court
based on the interrogation of the
officers of the testimony of the
officers in the trial that is actually
before this court concerning their
advice to him uh and the findings of the
court based on his understanding
the reading of the statement the
testimony coupled with this i believe
then that the court below
which clearly found that to be true
that he had been fully advised
he had a proper basis for finding all
these to exist except that there is no
quarrel
that he was not specifically advised
that he had a right to come is it your
position that a
record shows that he was advised of
these
rights
somehow some way in addition to
the legend on his confession that's my
question
yes
and uh how where is that i believe the
police officers testified
to the fact that they told him
uh
of his rights and that they also besides
telling him that perhaps it the record
is a little unclear
in both cases
as to exactly when it took place but i
believe the record supports a statement
that he was advised
specifically by them of his rights and
then he was
adverted to the paragraph and perhaps
even again the paragraph was read
to him but the record is not
really all or square it's not that clear
all right
let us assume that he was so advised and
i understand you've said the record is
not clear on the point
let us assume that he was advised of
these rights
and your opinion doesn't make any
difference
when he was advised
that is uh whether he was advised
at the commencement of the interrogation
or in an early stage of the
interrogation
or when he was advised only
when uh
he was
ready to sign the confession of the
written confession
so how can a difference in terms of the
issues before us assuming for a moment
that
that some
warning is going to be required or
should have been given or is it
then i would think uh
to be of any effect that must be given
before he's made any statement that
perhaps he might have refused to sign a
written confession certainly still the
oral statements could have been
introduced against him so you
think that the warning if necessary has
to be given prior to the interrogation
some meaningful time right i think it
have to be at some time
prior to the fact that
that after
if they used it before of course the
warning would mean nothing if they could
introduce what they had obtained from it
before they gave the warning
and what afterwards well now do you
believe that is it your
submission to us that a warning is
necessary
before a confession
in the absence of counsel
can be taken and subsequently introduced
in the truck
what is your position on that no my
position basically is
concerning the warning
is that each case
presents a factual situation in which
the court would have to determine or a
court or a judge or prosecutor some
level would have to make a determination
is whether or not a defendant
because of the circumstances surrounding
his confession
was denied a specific right whether it
be right to counsel the right to not be
compelled to testify against himself and
that a warning
or an age or a
literacy
the circumstances length of questioning
all these factors would be
important but i don't think you can pin
it to one simple
thing as a warning because
there are perhaps many situations we
could think of where a warning
would be completely inadequate well
tell me some of the factors that would
be relevant in the absence of a warning
uh his age his experience his background
the type of questioning the atmosphere
of the questioning
the length of questioning
time of
the time of day perhaps
all these factors you think what we
ought to do is to
devise something like the bets and
brainy rules special circumstances
well i think that's what the the
escobedo case
indicates in other words uh
i'm of course my opinion is biased and
uh i'm if it
if it is not something like that then
it's an it's an absolute
uh
right to counsel i don't think there can
be any in between unless some other
theory
uh
under the way i read the decisions of
this court there it's if it is an
absolute right to counsel the same sort
of right to counsel that attaches we're
not talking about right to counsel now
i'm talking about the warning when is
the warning necessary and
as i understand you you uh
say that if the warning is necessary if
it should be held to be constitutionally
necessary in the absence of counsel
then the warning has to be given at a
meaningful time i would think so
certainly
and then i proceeded to ask you or give
us the benefit of your views
as to
whether a warning was necessary and as i
understand it you say that you have to
look at the circumstances of each case i
would say not absolutely and then i ask
you what circumstances of each case what
are the relevant circumstances to look
for
in a particular case
and
how about this this particular case
is a psychiatric report to which you
refer
psychiatric report number two
and material variance with the one that
uh to which are i don't think so i'm not
a psychiatrist so i can't say it i don't
think i think both reports say in the
effect that
the man has an emotional illness that
should be treated but that he knew what
was going on uh both the reports say his
mental faculties whatever they were were
sharp acute he had no uh
no psychotic disorders i think they're
both they both say basically the same
thing
uh i think the diagnosis in the other
report was a sociopathic personality
so then if the
that's against brady test uh were
applied in the way that this court did
apply it uh prior to gideon
i suppose it's quite arguable that uh
miranda the petitioner here wasn't
planned no warning
would you agree it's arguable i have
extensively
argued the fact that
that he wasn't of such a nature
as an individual because of his mental
condition or his educational background
as to require
any more than he got he got everyone in
other words i'm saying he got every
warning except
the right the warning the specific
warning of the right to counsel he
didn't have council council wasn't
specifically denied to him
on the basis of request to retain
council the only possible
thing that happened to mr miranda
that
in my life assuming that he has the
capability of understanding it all
is the fact that he did not get the
specific warning of his right to counsel
well even if we assume that he got all
the other warnings and putting aside
question right council
assuming that the
record does show that we got these
warnings but still
is there any evidence uh
i have to ask you again uh
does the record show that he got it at
what you would call a meaningful time
yes i think the police officers they
were never pinned down as to when in
other words whether at 11 30 when they
went into interrogation room 2
they immediately warned him this was
never pinned down by either side but
they did say that he was warned and then
they went to elaborate that he was
warned
specifically
as i believe as my recollection serves
me correct in response to a specific
question concerning the statement they
said he was
the part of the statement was read to
him
again i
i believe that the court could find from
the record that he was warned at 11 30.
if the warning is required in this
particular case to protect his rights
and
and it's found as a matter of fact which
the court below did not find
that it was not given until uh the
written statement and i would suppose
that
it wasn't given at the proper time mr
nelson i certainly
don't want your views and only abuser i
don't want to explain anything
unfairly
but uh i want to
am i correct and inferring from what you
have just said next to my questions
that the state of arizona
does agree that there are occasions
when
the united states constitution
requires
that
a warning as to
the right to remain silent
uh
must be given
you're out of my offend to a person
who's in custody and
and it must be given at a meaningful
time do i correctly state the
position that you're
i don't think that the arizona supreme
court
has worded its
holdings and i say the course court the
case that followed miranda and referred
back to it concerning the point to
waiver and they go on to expand on their
thinking i don't believe the arizona
court has specifically said
that warnings as such
are of a constitutional dimension the
court has said that in some cases
warnings
may be required
in in a given case in fact in the golf
case which i cite
as the next case in the arizona court's
determination they say it's important
that the
that all steps be taken at the earliest
possible time when they're indicated by
the fact situation to ensure that the
state doesn't overreach and that the man
is given
every benefit of his rights under the
constitution but i don't believe they've
yet said as a constitutional dimension
any specific warning at any specific
situation
uh
needs to be given
yeah it's my it's my argument
concerning
the factors surrounding escobedo that if
escobedo is a completely distinct and
separate
determination of a sixth amendment right
as divorced from a fifth amendment right
which i think is pretty hard to do
then in order for it to be meaningful
and effective not just to the defendants
but to the
the people
of the state
of the country
it's got to announce a rule
which forbids affirmative conduct
on the basis on the basis of police
officers or prosecutors
uh calculated in a given situation
to deny the man the implementation of
his right whether it be the right to
counsel or the right
against compulsory self-incrimination as
i understand there's no right not to
incriminate
himself
the right is
for him not to be compelled whether it's
subtle compulsion or direct but it is
still
a right not to be compelled to
incriminate himself at least this is
this is my understanding and
he doesn't have a right not to sell not
to incriminate himself he has a right
not to be compelled to incriminate
himself by some means either direct or
devious
now i think
if the extreme position is adopted
that says
he has to either
have counsel at this stage
or
intelligently waive council
that
a serious problem
in the enforcement of our criminal law
will occur
uh
first of all
let us
make one thing certain we need no
empirical data
as to one factor what council
will do if he is actually introduced i'm
talking now about counsel for the
defendant there
at least among lawyers there can be no
doubt
as to what council for the defendant is
to do he is to represent him 100 percent
uh win lose or draw guilty or innocent
that's our system and when council is
introduced in interrogation
uh interrogation ceases
immediately why
well for one reason uh first of all
let's assume an uncommit i mean there
are several different situations but
assuming
council is immediately introduced and he
knows nothing about the case he's not
talked to his defendant he's appointed
say he's appointed an indigent defendant
who says
i want a lawyer i need a lawyer right
now i don't want to talk to the lawyer
he's given a lawyer
he talks to the defendant
first of all he stops the interrogation
until he can talk to them and i would
think he if he's going to represent him
he cannot allow him to say anything
until he finds out
what his story is what he's going to
stay is going to how it's going to
affect him so the interrogation
immediately would stop for that purpose
and then after he has had an opportunity
to confer with his client
let's assume another thing but
assume his client said yes i did it i'm
guilty
uh
had all the requisite intents he makes a
statement to his lawyer in confidence
that he did it
and asked his lawyer what she did what
he should do well the lawyer
maybe doesn't know his past history
maybe the lawyer would want to find out
what the police have if he can
and so maybe more time would
in order to properly represent him would
be taken up here
uh
time which there would be no
interrogation let's further assume that
he advises his client
well
i think you ought to confess
responsibility for a light sentence she
did it
they have
other evidence
or maybe they don't have any other
evidence let's say they don't have any
other evidence and uh
you can confess and the fellow says well
i don't want to confess i don't want to
go to the gas chamber if i don't have to
is there is there anything else that you
as my lawyer can do for me
well what does he got to tell him that i
under our system he's got to tell him
yes you don't have to say anything
there's and the fact that you don't say
anything can't in any way hurt you be
inferred otherwise
and we can put the state to its burden
of proof
and uh why does our system compel it
allow you to do that
well as i understand it
to do that yes i'm sure
it's my understanding that he is
well why does it do it who's what
[Music]
because we believe that it's right and
proper that the criminal defendant
not be deprived of his life liberty or
property without due process of law
i'm something about giving testimony
against yourself
right this is
what i mean this is just the one issue
where the lawyer has to guard all these
rights but i'm saying the practical
effect of introducing counsel
at the interrogation stage is going to
stop the interrogation for any and all
purposes except what council decides
will be in the best interests of his
defendant
otherwise council will not be doing his
job not about the same thing as a
practical effect an object of the
commandment which says he should not be
compelled to give evidence against
themselves
any difference between the objects and
purposes of the two what the lawyer
tells him and what the amendment for
certainly that's the object of what this
his lawyer is telling him
that the object of the amendment well
that is the question whether it's
of course his the fifth amendment he has
a right never to be compelled to
incriminate himself at whatever stage
and this is of course involving him a
knowledgeable
implementation of that right at this
time if he wants to
what i'm saying is
that the state
does not have to at this stage
insist on that right being enforced or
waived
because you be pre-trial
police interrogation does more
than just develop confessions or
incrimina it develops incriminating
statements
it develops exculpatory statements which
pin a story down to a defendant very
closely after the crime has been
committed or very closely after he's
been taken in police custody which
prevent
or effectively
make it unprofitable for him to purge
himself or change his testimony at the
trial should be anything fantastic in
the idea that the fifth amendment that
the protection against being compelled
to test forget oneself
might be read reasonably meaning there
should be no pre-trial
proceedings when he was there in the
possession of
the state
because i don't i don't
to me i think there is i think there's a
valid interest
uh with a valid interest of course if
they can convict him and more unless
they have been trying to convict you
right but i think that well and this is
another argument that i think must be
made our adversary system as such is not
completely adversary even at the trial
stage in a criminal prosecution because
cannon five of the uh
candidates of ethics of the american bar
association which are
law in arizona by rule of court
says that the duty of the prosecution is
not simply to go out and convict but is
to see that justice is done i i know
i've talked to manufacturing myself in
my short time i've gotten as much
satisfaction out of the cases which i
was compelled to confess error in a case
where a man has been deprived of his uh
rights by due process and i got the
satisfaction in being upheld in a in a
tight case
you give defendants access to
the uh state's uh evidence against him
in your state uh
mr flynn would tell you more about that
at the trial level i don't believe uh
that the rule has been interpreted very
broadly i think it's been interpreting
early i think he can get his own
statements and perhaps he can get police
officers reports
uh there is a rule providing for uh
motions but the judges as i understand
it have consumed that uh fairly narrowly
so that it is uh possible to
speculate isn't it that the
state has limitations places limitations
upon
its obligation to cooperate with the
defendant
has witnessed the denial of uh discovery
to the defendant discovery of the
evidence that the state has against him
yes of course i i'm sure the
prosecutors would 100 percent go along
with the full discovery for both sides
but what
[Music]
the defendant of course is compelled to
no discovery
no ordinary discovery procedures in the
in the
uh scope we think of them in a civil
case i i
i just say this today i'm not sure the
analogy is complete
when i was calling your attention is
that uh
there are
in our system uh there are limitations
upon the
degree of cooperativeness on both sides
it's not just that they
arrested person
as under the constitution a
privilege against self-incrimination and
it's also that
the state uh when it assumes an
adversary position
even before that time
uh takes advantage of certain uh
uh reticences shall i say
yes
to the accused surely it does but
there is no compulsion in fact
compulsion is to the contrary on the
defense side to cooperate whereas that
there is complete compulsion uh at least
by my interpretation of the law for the
prosecutor to do as much if it's
available to him to show that the
defendant's innocence proves guilty well
i think when we've established in this
color play that it that that's complete
is a little bit of an overstatement it
doesn't always work that way
i'm sure that's the case but this here
again is another point that i emphasize
this is no reason i don't think for a
constitutional rule which would
in effect
take care of what i consider to be the
exceptions to the rule rather than the
general practice
i might just say since i noticed my time
is about up
uh council made a statement to the
effect in answer to a question of one of
the justices i forget which one
something about that why miranda talked
to maybe he was raised to tell the truth
or our society you're raised to tell the
truth and respect authority this brings
another thing
into play i believe which is vitally
important and prosecutors in my state
consider it so
that
if
in fact in fact you either have counsel
or you don't and it thereby
seriously circumscribes interrogation
and confession
you eliminate
an early part of one of the most
important
principles hopefully in our criminal law
and that is to
not just to convict not just to deter
not just to put somebody away but to
rehabilitate and at the earliest
possible moment and
i don't have that many personal
experiences so we had a meeting with the
prosecutors in our state and
many of the cases
involving confessions and pre-trial
interrogation
uh were the cases where when a man has
at least admitted he has done something
wrong were cases where the defendants
uh
were much more
susceptible
to rehabilitation at this stage
if you foreclose this and you develop an
attitude in the police officers
you take a personal attitude away many a
hardened police officer
when he's developed a case of
tremendous circumstantial evidence
against a man and yet the man sits there
and keeps telling him
i didn't do it
uh he is going to wonder there's a
personal factor there he's going to
wonder why doesn't this man confess why
doesn't he
say something about doing it even
assuming now arguando that it's not
coercion that we
i have no argument that whatever
is
considered coercion whether it's subtle
or otherwise
should not be used but assuming that the
interrogation is good except for that
uh he's going to wonder and maybe he's
going to go out and examine that
eyewitness who saw him at two o'clock in
the morning under a dark street light
and and examine his other evidence
because he wonders that first of all he
ought to confess
here's all the evidence it's the final
facial case
this is wiped out
completely if
you terribly circumscribe this
particular pre-trial investigation this
particular personal element is out
and he can say well i got the evidence
maybe he's killed him maybe he's not i
didn't talk to him i don't know how he
acts how he how he turns up and i think
its defendants
could be hurt as much as
the prosecution
[Music]
general taylor
chief justice members of the court
the state of new york is
appearing
not only in the present case
of the miranda case
but in the ensuing four cases that have
been scheduled for executive arguments
in which these problems of the right
assistance council are raised
i think the state has
appeared here as amicus
uh numerous previous occasions when
there has been a
constitutional question in the general
field of criminal procedure
the uh nature of our interest is stated
in the opening stage of grief
and i do not believe that i need to
elaborate that orally
excuse me
i should add the brief has been
circulated
to the other states and has been joined
by something over half i think about 27
other states as well as puerto rico and
virgin islands
now i'm trying to say what i have to say
in in less than the allotted time
and uh my task of brevity is the easier
because
some things i might otherwise say i
think will be said much better by others
and i also try to say a few things that
as i read the briefs
no one else is going to say or at least
say in the same manner
the factor common to all five of these
cases
uh is that a confession is received in
evidence
uh which was taken
uh when council were not present
and when there had been no waiver of
counsel
and therefore a contention that runs
commonly through all five of them
is the one that emerged i think most
clearly and answered justice black's
question
uh as to whether this is a matter of
constitutional dimension under the fifth
amendment or for that matter the sixth
or the due process clause
you said one thing common is there
another thing common as to where they
were when the confessions were made well
the cases uh well they're all in
detention that's also
all
in a state of detention
yes
uh otherwise than that there is quite a
spectrum of circumstances this these
cases uh reveal the other the
surrounding circumstances are not
not uniform
now may i just state what the thrust of
our position is very briefly before
uh indicating likewise its limits and
why we are taking this position
uh our contention is that
in so far as these cases present a
constitutional claim
that a valid confession cannot be taken
unless council is present or has been
waived
uh that that
claim in constitutional terms in the
constitutional dimension
uh is not sound in other words justice
black's question we would answer in the
negative that the fifth amendment uh
cannot be uh should not be
read as requiring council to be present
at the time the confession is taken i
will come to my reasons for that very
presently
uh our secondary position is that
if the court should
uh decide to enunciate a rule of that
sort in constitutional terms
or
other new rules
pertaining to the validity of
pre-arraignment confessions
those should not be applied
retroactively but should be prospective
only
now before speaking in in support of
those two positions and i intend to
spend most of my time on the first one
uh may i make clear
uh the uh the limits of our position
here and what we are not saying because
i think this is of almost equal
importance uh we are not taking any
position for either affirmance or
reversal of any of these five cases
uh
that is because all five of them
as we see it involve
problems or possible problems that that
go beyond the limits of our contention
here
in the miranda case it's just been
argued uh there is obvious divisive
division of opinion about the
characteristics of the defendant
about whether the warning that mr
justice fartister's questions were
directed to
uh
was given at a meaningful stage what the
significance of that warning is in legal
terms
uh the other five cases involve
questions of trial procedure in which we
are not presently interested
uh they also two of them involve a
period of long detention from which
council are making arguments
derived from the mcnabb uh mallory uh
principles
uh we are not uh taking a position on
those matters and therefore we could not
uh say that in any one of these five
cases we are supporting
uh an affirmance or a reversal
secondly
uh may i make quite clear that we are
not saying
that new rules about uh
requiring council to be present when
an investigation is taken interrogations
made or confession taken we are not
saying that such rules are necessarily
uh unwise uh without merit
we say
that these
are not matters of constitutional
dimension but we do not say they might
not be very wise rules to adopt
in fact we are saying that this whole
problem
of the assistance of council at the
pre-arraignment stage
uh can we think uh be more appropriately
and perhaps better dealt with
in the legislative dimension and in the
area of judicial policy rather than in
purely constitutional terms
now of course in so far as we say
there's no constitutional basis here our
position cuts against the uh the
defendants but as i repeat we are not
taking a position against
such rules
found in other ways through legislative
means through
judicial policy or otherwise
now
may please the court the inclusion in
these five cases of one federal case
uh the west gilbert case number 761
uh i think underlines this uh
distinction that i have been endeavoring
to state
and it also discloses uh the one respect
in which i think our position
departs from that was taken by the
solicitor general
as a federal case uh this being a a
confession taken by federal agents
introduced in evidence uh in a federal
prosecution
i would suppose that the westover case
is susceptible of disposition in
non-constitutional terms under this
court's
federal supervisory jurisdiction uh as
enunciated in in the mcnabb uh mallory
cases in that general line of authority
uh as i read the solicitor general's
brief however he is
he is saying not only that the
constitution
does not raise a requirement of the
presence of counsel
but is also saying that such a rule
should not be
laid down by this court
as a matter of
judicial policy the way it was done in
the map mallory
our position does not extend to that
second step
uh we do not take any position one way
or the other on it uh
i think it's entirely appropriate to say
though
that that would be a dimension in which
we would consider uh this court might
very appropriately uh deal with the
matter
[Music]
one further thing understood
i'll make it very can we do that uh with
respect to uh
the states
no i no miss justice supporters i was
pointing out that the westover case
brings out that it's only in the
westover case that you can do that so
what you're saying is that we might uh
lay down such a rule some way somehow
short of constitutional basis
for the federal courts and leave the
states alone that's what it comes down
to well uh that's correct
the states are of course affected only
by the constitutional dimension the
federal courts are subject to a broader
range of review
uh i might add that in new york
our own court of appeals has
uh has noted and acted upon
this very distinction between decisions
in the constitutional dimension and
consider and decisions in the domain of
judicial policy what's the difference
between this uh problem in
those terms and the problem that this
court handled in gideon
right to counsel
well if your honor is asking whether the
what the reasons for drawing the
distinction between the trial stage and
the pre-trial stage may be
yes and the terms in which you're
discussing
in other words would new york state have
taken the position that
gideon was
wrongly decided
wrongly decided no
and indeed in new york state this would
be treated now as a matter of
constitutional requirement
there's no question about that in my
mind
but in the choice
in the dimension we're talking about
that is the pre-arrangement right to
council a new york state held prior to
escobedo's justice force
but where as an escobedo there was a an
interference by the police authorities
with
the access of counsel to his client
that this was in the constitutional
dimension
a violation of the defendant's rights
this case is cited with proven this
could be no decision
uh just last year it went further than
that the court of appeals
uh and held that if there is a um
a telephone call from council to the
police authorities asking that there be
no more questioning of uh the client
that any question that takes place after
that cannot result in
admissible admissions or confessions but
when the further question was raised
uh in a case where council arrived at
the station
while a confession was being taken
uh the state made the contention that
that part of the confession that took
place before council arrived could be
admitted and not the latter part general
i don't know
i just want to say that
i think the problem is uh whether it's
not too late in the day to make that
kind of extinction i'm asking the
question that is to say that once this
court has
uh made the rulings that it has made and
gideon escobedo i wonder if
it's still uh
much availed argument we ought to draw
the kind of a line that you're
suggesting here
well that brings me back to mr justice
black's question and it's relation to
the ones that uh that you have been
putting this justice for us
and that is whether there is anything in
the constitution uh either in the sixth
amendment assistance of council clause
in the due process clause or in the
protection against self-incrimination
whether any of those clauses together or
conjointly
should be read
as requiring council in the
pre-arraignment stage
now it seems to me that if one is going
to approach that question
uh one must
enunciate a constitutional theory
are we looking to history and original
meaning of the constitution
or are we looking to uh
contemporary standards is the
constitution to be treated as fluid uh
with
with different and perhaps more rigorous
meanings uh obtaining by common consent
at a later time or are we to look to the
original understanding this has been
called
now i suggest with all respect mr
justice ford is that in those terms
uh it's very difficult
uh to support the contentions being made
here and the situation is quite
different from gideon quite different
i forget the exact number of states
that already were furnishing council uh
in all criminal trials the time of
gideon but my recollection is there
wasn't more than a handful
that weren't already doing this as a
matter of state practice
therefore one had a a very broad
practice and consensus
in the states on this very point the
same thing if i may say so
uh was true in the map case to a lesser
extent
uh in map you had about half the states
that who were applying the exclusionary
rule
and the trend was solidly in that
direction california had changed its
view between wolf and map
so that in both of these situations you
had a solid basis in practical
experience in the states and really your
decision was not revolutionary in those
terms but in the dimension that we're
now talking about
i don't know of a single state
that presently
excludes confessions that are taking
pre-arraignment from the absence of
council i don't think there is such
jurisdiction
but it doesn't
isn't it the fact that most of the
states have a
regulation that a prisoner shall be
taken
forth with to uh before a magistrate and
they're advised of his rights
and so forth and doesn't frankly every
state to the union have a
applause uh
uh
preventing people from being compelled
to testify against themselves indeed
also just yes and uh so in that respect
we're not much different than gideon are
we
well they weren't there they're just an
awful lot of states that weren't uh
weren't uh
a giving council
up to the time to get in they had a rule
on it maybe but they weren't they
weren't according my understanding is
that at the time of gideon all but a
very few states were indeed according
full ride to council of the trial stage
which is what you're getting related to
and what i'm saying is that we have no
such
basis in precedent and established
practice when we are coming to the
pre-arraignment stage
nor do we have institutional doctrine
that's uh
something that indicates wisdom but
that's not the same thing as saying that
that is uh
that uh that's not addressed to the
question of historical interpretation of
the constitution no indeed uh on the
basis of historical interpretation i
think one would be hard put to it to
find any basis for finding the right to
counsel the pre-arrangement stage much
less the right to be furnished council
if you are indigent
uh and therefore it seems to me the
stronger argument for the uh claim
advanced here is not the historical
basis but the common consensus basis
and as on that basis i was suggesting mr
justice lourdes that we we don't have
the gideon situation here at all this
court is being asked to enunciate a rule
for which there is no uh basis in the
problem practice
gideon there was no claim made that
there was
the result that achieved their uh
arrival and gideon was based on a
historical interpretation of the
constitution
it's based upon a
reinterpretation of the general
constitutional guarantee and for that
reinterpretation there was abundant
support in what one could see around one
and a commonly accepted view that this
is a very desirable thing we don't have
that here thank you
general you have you haven't gotten your
second point and they're only two or
three minutes until
closing time would you mind addressing
yourself to that on the question of
retroactivity on retroactivity
well at swings to chief justice that
point flows i would think as a matter of
logic from our first proposition if that
be accepted if as we see it
this is not a constitutional claim based
on an original understanding
if this is a matter that will be evolved
from contemporary practice and changing
standards
uh why then it seems to me that to apply
such a rule retroactively
uh presents considerable conceptual
difficulties and i find no conceptual
difficulties in a prospective
application the court has confronted us
now twice in linked letter and
in tien
we have set out in our brief the reasons
why it seems to us the considerations
the court went on there
uh are applicable here
i might say also that uh that if we are
to um
to hope for legislative progress and
for uh action within the states by their
own courts why a principle of
retroactivity may be a damper on change
and
improvement rather than a stimulus to it
this would tend to freeze things and
make people reluctant
to develop new practices that if
everything else has to be unwound going
all the way back to the beginning
to make the new practice prevail
very well
[Music]
the supreme court decided that suspects
must be advised of their rights upon
arrest and before interrogation begins
opportunities to exercise these rights
must be available to the suspect
throughout the interrogation
these rights have come to be known as
the miranda rights
chief justice earl warren delivered the
opinion of the court in miranda versus
arizona
you've been watching c-span's america
and the courts and listening to the oral
argument in the case miranda versus
arizona
in two weeks we'll air the audio from
the oral argument in the pentagon papers
case which was heard by the supreme
court and decided 25 years ago this
month
in that case lawyers for the new york
times and washington post newspapers
argued that their free press first
amendment rights would be violated by
any court-ordered ban on the publication
of leaked documents from a top-secret
defense department history of the
vietnam war
join us in two weeks for a special
two-hour america and the courts
beginning at its regular time 7 pm
eastern
scheduled to air the last week in june
about the time the supreme court wraps
up business for this term a review of
the major cases
next week on america and the courts a
profile of chief justice william
rehnquist
this month marks the 10th anniversary of
his nomination as chief justice by
president reagan
we'll hear from people who have worked
with him on the court and air highlights
from his speeches and appearances during
the past 10 years
america and the courts airs saturday
evenings at 7 pm 4 p.m for our viewers
on the west coast
here are some supreme court related
anniversaries for this month
retired justice byron white turned 79
this month he was the first of president
kennedy's two appointments to the court
and served for 31 years
chief justice william rehnquist
celebrates his 10th anniversary as chief
justice on june 17th
and we'll take a look at his tenure on
the court next week on america and the
courts
justice clarence thomas the youngest
supreme court justice turns 48 on june
23rd
10 years ago this month president reagan
nominated antonin scalia as an associate
justice
and this month marks the 75th
anniversary of chief justice william
howard taft's nomination and
confirmation
he's the only person in history to have
been both president of the united states
and chief justice
this concludes america and the courts
for this week
[Music]
for more information about the federal
judicial process c-span offers justice
for all the booklet examines the supreme
court's history and its influence today
for your copy send a check or money
order for 5.95 plus three dollars
shipping and handling to justice for all
c-span publications 1616 main street
lynchburg virginia 24504
and tonight on our companion network
c-span 2 about books our new program
focusing on authors ideas and the
business of books
first tonight at nine eastern and
pacific in birmingham alabama melissa
fay green reads from her book the